[Musique]
des photos prises par des photos
journalistes d'une agence de presse
danoise sont récemment devenue virale
sur le web
ces photos de gens qui font la file dans
la rue ont été prises avec des objectifs
de caméra différents
pourquoi pour prouver qu'avec une seule
et même scène
on peut raconter plusieurs histoires
tuvalu en jaser avec notre collègue
photojournaliste ivanoh demers ça lui va
non tu étais ici hier pour prendre des
photos des gens qui faisaient la file
devant une succursale de la sq udc pour
montrer qu'avec une seule scène on peut
raconter plusieurs histoires dit nous a
plus que tu as fait aujourd'hui comme
convoi il ya pas mal moins de monde
meilleur quand je suis venu y avait
peut-être 30 40 personnes qui est en
ligne qui l exercice qu'on m'avait donné
un peu c'était d'être capable
d'illustrer avec mes deux appareils
comment qu'on peut montrer la même scène
avec différentes focales que les effets
que sa part à ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris
deux focales différentes 400 mm dimon
mon grand âge j'ai commencé en prenant
les gens de 12 400 mm image très très
très compréhensible ça donne vraiment
l'impression que les gens sur colis
tranquillement par des instances un
petit peu sur le côté
et puisqu'on se décale plus que l'effet
est moins parce que notre oeil car mieux
la distance entre chaque personne sauce
avec la même focal
évidemment si on dit un autre bar de la
rue par après kir offert une photo au
grand temps elles ont vraiment qu'ils
sont à 2 m nous on choisit des angles
différents pour illustrer une scène
c'est après plus loin dans la chaîne
qu'il faut aussi que les gens
comprennent c'est quoi la situation est
bien là l'illustré de la documenter
parce que le bout de la chaîne ce qui
arrive parfois c'est qu'une fois que le
photojournaliste envoie ses photos avec
différents zones ferme perspective il se
peut qu'à l'autre bout on comprenne - un
peu ce qui s'est fait et puis qu'on
titre les nouvelles autrement piscine ou
la désinformation peut s'opérer wyss a
pu s'opérer parce que le photographe à
la balle aussi fait bien son travail
puis décrit bien la scène puis que la
personne a loupé pour soi les 8-9 image
mais là on comprend très bien la scène
là quelqu'un peut être de mauvaise foi
puis dire ah ben si tu crois au canada
on va dire qu'il y avait pas de
distanciation social on prend la 1ère
puis on n'a pas trop de contexte puis
bon ok c'est paul corps qui moi de mon
côté si j'en voyais seulement une image
très très très serré de dos je mets pas
aucun contexte il ya personne au bout de
la chaîne qui va comprendre qu'ils vont
passer capot dispensation donc il faut
que de moments aussi choix responsable
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ce
dossier à les lire l'article de ma
collègue bouchra wathiq sur notre site
web
et n'oubliez pas d'adhérer à notre
groupe facebook et pourquoi pas aussi
regagner notre émission en ondes les
samedis dimanches ici rdi salut
[Musique]